after almost fifty years on the Upper
East Side the Whitney Museum of American
Art has a new address it's moving back
into lower Manhattan it's a huge deal
just in terms of the size that we have
now and the availability of the
collection just so many more people the
new Whitney sits at the end of the High
Line a park that gets nearly five
million visitors a year we're not
worried that it's going to be empty and
you're going to be able to wander
through the galleries alone we worry
more that it's going to be packed and we
have to figure out how you're going to
have a wonderful experience in the
galleries the Whitney wanted to expand
for decades over the last 25 years there
were three plans to add on to its old
home on Madison Avenue what was it about
this plan to you that made it appealing
to you and other members of the board
the director I think Adam Weinberg the
Alice Pratt brown director of the
Whitney is a true visionary
and he made this happen Weinberg had his
work cut out for him about seven years
ago is when we began and was actually a
bit more protracted process than we
would have hoped because just after we
began 2008 came with a financial crisis
not a good time to retire and we had
raised a certain amount of money but we
basically put the project on a semi
pause at that time
the economy started to recover and in
2013 the board's former chairman Leonard
Lauder gave the museum a hundred and
thirty million dollars we wanted a
building that felt large enough that we
could do and expand our programs show
more of our collection have more
education programs accommodate more
visitors but at the same time have a
building in a sense of circulation that
people would not feel lost or
overwhelmed for museum's expansion is a
tricky thing MoMA continues to attract
long lines of visitors years after it
added more space but the American folk
art museum couldn't afford the payments
on its building ultimately it moved to a
space one-sixth its former size but the
Whitney's director is not worried we
have a very good financial model that
should sustain this institution for the
next hundred years part of that model is
finding new ways to make money I hardly
know any museums anymore that don't rent
some aspect of their spaces at some time
it's it's a necessity we don't have you
know ongoing government support or
ongoing income streams you have to earn
income a non-profit art museum defines
success differently Weinberg says it
can't be all about revenues and reviews
it's about who and what the museum has
championed you had to look back 10 years
and say was the Whitney on it 10 years
ago were they there with the right group
of artists the right ideas the right
thoughts